[Music]
this is the story of a throne at the
heart of an empire casting a shadow over
three lives the empress brought down by
assassins the daughter who watched her
mother die and the man who had torn out
his heart to keep the boat safe now his
lessons have made Emily strong but with
an empire at stake will that be enough
blood spilled from the throne and
dunwall laughs against Caracas distant
shores knows what's happened in the
jewel of the south
there are answers
but new riddles too
in this city are unimaginable wonders
soldiers with clock with minds and
electromagnetic hearts inventions that
will elevate every citizens across them
any of metallic feet
a young Empress reaches into the void
itself her father touched the void too
and paid a heavy price
there's no one like Delilah survival and
ambition art and magic with a cunning
that makes sycophants of those around
her now she's got the throne but her
eyes are set on a much greater prize in
Canoga there's always a choice
mercy or revenge Savior or assassin
what would you give up to take back
what's yours